Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Was ist los in den Europäischen Ligen? Vor einigen Wochen haben wir zuletzt auf die Premier League geblickt, das wollen wir heute wieder tun und ein bisschen Champions League, vielleicht auch, zusammen mit Fußball-Autoren-Legende Raphael Honigstein. Raphael, schön, dass du mal mit dabei bist im Rasenfunk.
Aber trotzdem sehr nett.
Ehre, wem Ehre gebührt. Und wenn ich all die Dinge, die du so machst, in dieses Intro gepackt hätte, dann hätte es ja auch nicht geklappt. Denn du bist in Podcasts zu hören, du trittst in Fernsehsendungen auf, du hast Bücher geschrieben, unter anderem eines zu Jürgen Klopp. Das ist jetzt das Aktuellste. Deswegen dachte ich, Fußball-Autoren-Legende fasst das doch ganz gut zusammen. Okay, also wir können noch ein Bescheiden dazu addieren zu deinen Eigenschaften. Aber wir wollen ja gar nicht über dich sprechen, sondern über den englischen Fußball. Und jetzt hat aber die Aktualität dafür gesorgt, dass es sich nicht nur auf die Premier League beschränkt. Es gab ein Champions League-Viertelfinale zwischen Liverpool und Manchester City. Mit 3 zu 0 ging das für Liverpool aus. Und ich hatte den Eindruck, das war so eins der klassischsten Klopp-Spiele aller Zeiten. Würdest du mir da zustimmen?
Absolut. Das kam auch nicht so 100 Prozent überraschend, weil er im Vorfeld richtig dafür plädiert hat, das Publikum zu aktivieren und alles daran zu setzen, gegen den spielerisch sicher stärkeren Gegner, wie man so schön sagt, alles rauszuhauen in die Ductus. Und das funktionierte halt zumindest eine Hälfte lang einfach fantastisch, mit einer unheimlichen Schärfe, mit einer großartigen Effizienz im Strafraum, mit all diesen Doppelungen und Verdreifachungen, die man auch in den besten Dortmund-Jahren erlebt hatte, wo auf jeden Fall die Gegenspieler auch immer irgendwie umzingelt waren. Und dazu noch die Kulisse. Also es war ein bewegendes Erlebnis, mit einem wirklich fantastischen Resultat.
Ja, das ist ja klar, dass das jetzt aus Liverpooler Sicht ausgesprochen ist. Das kommt einem als deutscher Fußball-Beobachter auch gar nicht so unbekannt vor, denn genau das haben wir bei den Duellen von Dortmund gegen Bayern oder zum Beispiel auch Dortmund gegen Real Madrid, hat man das häufiger gesehen, dass das Klopp-Mannschaften einfach können. Hättest du dir eine Reaktion von City erwartet in der ersten Halbzeit? Also die wurden davon überrollt, deutlich, und hatten natürlich auch das Pech, dass sofort in der 12. Minute 1-0, in der 20. Minute 2-0 wunderbarer Fernschuss von Oxlade-Chamberlain – also da klappt auch alles für Liverpool – aber man hätte darauf ja auch reagieren können. Und sonst ist das das, was man Pep Guardiolas Mannschaften unterstellt, dass sie sehr fluide sind, in ihren Systemen, in ihrer Art und Weise zu spielen. Und trotzdem konnte man dem in der ersten Halbzeit keinen Einhalt gebieten.
Das stimmt. Die ersten 10 Minuten, 12 Minuten, eigentlich bis zu dem Tor, hatte City das Spiel dominiert, mit den typischen Passfolgen und auch so ein bisschen, ja, die Atmosphäre runtergedimmt und man spürte schon so eine gewisse Unruhe im Stadion, aber dann gleich eigentlich mit dem ersten oder zweiten Angriff hat Liverpool getroffen. Und dann setzte, wie wirklich Guardiola auch unumwunden zugab, so dieser leichte Kontrollverlust ein, der dann wirklich unglücklicherweise für City gleich zu insgesamt drei Gegentoren führte. Und danach haben sie sich eigentlich gerade zum Ende der ersten Hälfte und dann in der kompletten zweiten Hälfte wieder auf ihre eigenen Stärken besonnen und hatten auch eigentlich viele Gelegenheiten, große Gelegenheiten herauszuspielen. Nur der letzte Ball stimmte nicht so ganz. Also ich denke, wenn jetzt Pep sich das Spiel nochmal anschaut, kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass er nicht zu sich sagt, ich habe irgendwie was falsch gemacht oder wir müssen irgendwie einen Plan B entwickeln, wie es ja so schnell und schön immer heißt, sondern wir haben unser Spiel nicht richtig durchbekommen. Wir haben nicht in den entscheidenden Situationen in und am Strafraum den entscheidenden Ball gespielt, die Laufwege haben nicht gestimmt. Also er wird sich eher auf diese Sachen konzentrieren, denn City hat ja genug vom Spiel und genug vom Ball und auch mit einem sehr viel besseren Ergebnis aus diesem Abend rauszugehen, was auch Klopp, glaube ich, nicht mit falscher Bescheidenheit, sondern wirklich mit Ehrlichkeit auch zugegeben hat, der gesagt hat, also City war nicht schlecht, die waren sogar ziemlich gut, aber für uns ist eigentlich so alles gelaufen in diesem Spiel, alles richtig gelaufen.
Ja, also ich glaube wirklich, so stellvertretend steht das 2 zu 0. Dass da der Ball verloren wird von City, das tut sehr weh, aber dass er ihn dann auch wirklich aus 20 Metern in den Winkel haut. Ja, das passiert hat dann so einen besonderen Abend, an den sich, glaube ich, alle Liverpool-Fans noch eine Weile erinnern könnten. Wer weiß, wo das Liverpool noch hinträgt. Ich habe heute einen Artikel gelesen, der auch gesagt hat – Entschuldigung, Guardiola müsse jetzt im Rückspiel von seinem Plan A abweichen. Da würde ich aber gegenhalten, genau dieser Plan A hat ja im September auch zu einem 5 zu 0 Heimsieg von City gegen Liverpool geführt. Bei dir glaube ich jetzt auch schon so rauszuhören, dass du sagst, naja, sie müssen einfach ihr Spiel besser umsetzen. Wie ist denn die Debatte da gerade in britischen Journalismus?
Naja, diese Debatte wurde das ganze letzte Jahr geführt, als Guardiola für seine Verhältnisse sehr enttäuschend abgeschnitten. Jetzt hat er natürlich die Premier League schon gewonnen, ob es jetzt am Samstag schon passiert im Derby oder nicht, ist eigentlich zweitrangig und hat im Endeffekt allen gezeigt, dass sie falsch lagen mit dieser Plan B oder wir müssen uns anpassen und so weiter. Mit diesem Tenor, er hat noch mehr City in diese Mannschaft reingetragen oder noch mehr Guardiola, besser gesagt, natürlich auch mit dem nötigen Kleingeld versehen, um da noch ein paar Potsitze dazu zu kaufen. Aber ich sehe überhaupt nicht die Notwendigkeit, das irgendwie anders zu machen. Ganz abgesehen davon, müsste sich auch Klopp genau das Gleiche anhören, wenn er jetzt verloren hätte. Dann hätte man gesagt, na ja, immer dieses Umschaltspiel, Konterspiel, müssen die nicht mal ein bisschen anders spielen. Das wird immer bei Trainern, die eine sehr identifizierbare Spielweise haben, immer als erstes angeführt. Dass sozusagen das System zu starr ist, dass man sich da irgendwie ändern muss. Aber diese Trainer halten regelmäßig dagegen. Na ja, wir gewinnen aber die meisten Spiele damit. Und man kann auch mal wie Guardiola ein drittes Spiel in der Saison verlieren in Liverpool. Ich sehe das ein bisschen anders. Allerdings muss man eines noch dazu sagen, dass 5-0 stimmt, aber da ist auch so ein kleiner Stern dabei. Weil Liverpool bis zur 20. Minute, bis zur roten Karte von Sadio Mane, eigentlich ist es ähnlich wie jetzt auch in Anfield, unheimliche Probleme für City kreiert hat mit wahnsinnigem Konterspiel vor allem Salah, hat dagegen John Stones in dem Abend oder in dem Nachmittag wahnsinnig viel Unruhe gesorgt, konnte aber da nicht richtig abschließen. Also man war mindestens ebenwörtig gewesen und daraus schöpft auch Liverpool und Klopp die Hoffnung, dass es, obwohl dieses Ergebnis erstmal als Warnung steht, mit elf Mannen doch ziemlich knapp und auch im Sinne von Liverpool ausgehen kann.
Also ich glaube vor allem das nicht kassierte Auswärtsgegentor von City, das wird wahnsinnig helfen. Denn Liverpool ist eine Umschaltmannschaft, das ist ja fast schon eine Binsenweisheit und da wird es Gelegenheiten geben. Wir hatten im letzten Kurzpass, wo ich mit Uli Hebel von der Zone auf die Premier League geblickt habe, hatten wir danach eine kleine Debatte mit einigen Hörern und Hörern, die fanden, dass Liverpool so schlecht weggekommen wäre, weil Uli damals gesagt hat, mit Blick auch auf diese Niederlage in Swansea, nachdem man zu Hause gegen Manchester City in der Liga verloren hatte, dass es das genau gewonnen hatte, genau 4 zu 3, Entschuldigung, und dann verloren hatte in Swansea, dass das typisch Liverpool immer noch wäre und dass das auch im Klopp noch nicht aus der Mannschaft rausbekommen hätte. Wie siehst du denn seine Rolle bei Liverpool? Jetzt mal auch versuchen wir uns mal zu lösen von diesem goldenen Abend jetzt unter der Woche.
Also diese typisch Liverpool-Debatte, das ist typisch Liverpool. Diese Idee, dass ein verlorenes Spiel in fünf Monaten jetzt sozusagen zeigt, dass alles wieder eigentlich gar nicht so gut ist. Man kann der Mannschaft einiges vorwerfen und sie steckt sicher noch in der Entwicklung und muss sich auch im Ballbesitzspiel, das besser geworden ist, immer noch weiter verbessern. Aber dass gerade viele Swansea-Spiele dieses Jahr dabei gewesen wären, das kann man eben nicht sagen. Swansea sticht deswegen heraus, weil es die Ausnahme war, zusammen mit dem West Brom Pokal aus, was sehr peinlich war natürlich. Ansonsten hat Liverpool diese kleinen Spiele, mit denen man ganz große Probleme noch hatte in der letzten Saison, alle mehr oder weniger souverän gewonnen und hat eher in den Spitzen-Duellen Probleme gehabt. Ich sehe das ein bisschen anders. Ich sehe, dass die Mannschaft Fortschritte macht und unheimlich aus dem herausholt, was sie eigentlich hat. Das ist gar nicht so wahnsinnig, wie wenn man sich zum Beispiel das Mittelfeld mal anschaut. Das sind alles ganz brave, aufaufragungsvoll kämpfende Leute. Aber so richtige Spielkultur ist da seit dem Weggang von Philipp Coutinho eigentlich nicht vorhanden. Die Abwehr ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so schlecht wie ihr Ruf, aber auch nicht so wahnsinnig prominent besetzt, dass man vorstellen könnte, dass sie die Champions League gewinnt. Aber das kann passieren, weil sie im Kollektiv so wahnsinnig viel erreichen. Da sind wir natürlich wieder sofort bei Dortmund. Man hat auch erst hinterher eigentlich gesehen, dass diese Spieler vielleicht einzeln gar nicht so gut waren, weil sie anderswo viel weniger funktioniert haben.
Ja, sehr interessanter Punkt. Wenn man sich das Restprogramm von Liverpool anguckt, dann sieht das jetzt noch mit der kleinen Klammer, dass wir nicht wissen, wie weit es in der Champions League noch gehen könnte, sieht das alles ganz machbar aus. In der Liga liegt man zwei Punkte hinter Tabellenplatz 2 mit Manchester und das City weg ist. Also hinter United liegt man natürlich, das ist ja schon völlig klar. Es gibt im Grunde drei Mannschaften, die sich um diesen zweiten Tabellenplatz ein Triel liefern. Okay, da habe ich mich jetzt vermoderiert. United, Liverpool und die Spurs. Würdest du der These zustimmen, dass es vor allem Liverpool und den Spurs auch richtig etwas bedeuten würde, auf diesen zweiten Platz zu landen? Und bei United ist es dann eher so zähneknirschend, dass ausgerechnet auch noch der Stadtrivale die Liga so dominiert.
Ja, also für Liverpool würde es natürlich einfach dieses Momentum ein bisschen weiter befeuern und diese Idee, dass man einfach näher kommt. Man ist, glaube ich, seit dem Benitez-Tage nicht mehr Zweiter geworden. Doch, Entschuldigung, vielleicht unter den Rodgers in dem einen Jahr, genau. Das war natürlich ein großer Ausreißer nach oben und ansonsten war man sehr froh, wenn man vierter wurde in den letzten Jahren. Wenn man die Saison stark beenden könnte und natürlich vielleicht auch in der Champions League noch ein bisschen was macht, dann wächst einfach mit jedem Erfolg, mit jedem kleinen Schritt nach vorne, wächst einfach der Glaube an dieses Projekt. Das ist zwischendurch auch mal ein bisschen gewackelt. Nicht im Verein, auch nicht in der Mannschaft, aber so in der Außenwahrnehmung, weil man das Gefühl hatte, das ging eigentlich nicht schnell genug. Warum ist er nach zwei Jahren immer noch irgendwie nur 4. oder 5.? Das würde schon ein bisschen was bringen. Bei den Spurs wurden sie jetzt schon ein paar Mal relativ knapp hinter den Meistern, 2. oder 3. und das hat eigentlich gar nicht so viel jetzt bewirkt. Wichtig ist natürlich für die, dass sie wieder in die Champions League kommen, im neuen Stadion und diesen wirklich unheimlichen Aufschwung unter Pochettino weiter unterstreichen. Bei United, naja, jeder Platz hinter City, jeder Punkt hinter City tut weh. Wenn Morini wirklich noch 3. oder 4. wird, wird das natürlich immer schwieriger, den Leuten wahrzumachen, dass dieser Ergebnis-Fußball ohne großartige Ergebnisse irgendwann mal dann doch wieder die großen Titel bringen könnte. Also sie haben im Endeffekt da ein bisschen mehr zu verlieren als die anderen. Dafür können sie aber noch den FA-Pokal gewinnen und das wäre dann vielleicht auch ein halbwegs persönliches Ende für ManUnited. Aber ich glaube, das zeigen auch so die letzten Jahre, dass sich hinterher nicht wirklich die Leute unbedingt genau erinnern, ob man jetzt 2. oder 3. oder 4. wurde, gerade weil ja auch das Qualifikationsspiel wegfällt für den 4. im nächsten Jahr.
Die vorderen vier marschieren ja auch in der Liga ganz gut, aber da hinten bei Chelsea und Arsenal beginnen dann die Mannschaften, die immer mal wieder auch jüngst ins Stolpern gekommen sind. Über beide haben wir auch schon vor fünf Wochen mal länger gesprochen. Gerade Arsenal hat jetzt noch so die Europa League als Champions League-Umweg, 4 zu 1 gegen ZSK und Moskau zu Hause gewonnen und jetzt die große Hoffnung irgendwie vielleicht darüber, die Champions League zu erreichen. Hat sich denn an der Situation bei Arsenal, an der Wahrnehmung von Arsenal, etwas verändert durch die Transfers, die stattgefunden haben im Winter?
Das kann man gar nicht so leicht beantworten. Also natürlich kamen mit Aubameyang und Mkhitaryan so ein bisschen das Gefühl auf, Arsenal will es jetzt nochmal wissen und greift nochmal an und trennt sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen von der vorsichtigen Transferpolitik der letzten Jahre. Der große Schwung, die große Verbesserung hat sich aber nicht eingestellt. Mir hat es heute die neuesten Nachrichten sagen, dass Mkhitaryan wahrscheinlich schwerer verletzt ist und vielleicht auch nicht mehr spielen wird diese Saison. Aubameyang macht das gut, aber die Probleme sind ja bei Arsenal nicht im Sturm oder nicht unbedingt, wenn es darum geht, Tore zu schießen und schön zu spielen, sondern die Probleme sind ja schon seit Jahren, seit Jahrzehnten, muss man fast sagen, die richtige Balance und auch der Matchplan ohne Ball. Und da fürchte ich, wird sich so schnell nichts ändern, erst wenn der neue Trainer kommt.
Und weißt du, wie der Trainer heißen wird?
Ich weiß nicht, wie der Trainer heißen wird. Ich glaube, dass es auch bei Arsenal im Verein niemand weiß, weil man sich derzeit – das ist der Stand der Dinge, soweit ich weiß – auch gar nicht intensiv mit einem neuen Trainer befassen kann, weil der Jetzige keine Anstalten macht, zu gehen. Ich glaube, im Verein ist niemand wirklich bereit, den ein Jahr vor Ablauf seiner Karriere vor die Tür zu setzen. Also das ist immer noch Wengers Entscheidung. Mit jedem Sieg in der Europa League kann er die Sache länger herauszögern. Und er spielt natürlich auch auf Zeit, denn Ende Mai wird er sowieso nicht so wahnsinnig stark besetzter Trainer sein, was ja die Bayern unter anderem merken, noch leerer sein. Also ich gehe eher davon aus, dass er noch mal ein Jahr weiter macht, was für die Arsenal-Fans erstmal keine gute Nachricht ist, aber vielleicht es ihm irgendwie halt ermöglicht, noch versöhnlich aus dieser Geschichte rauszukommen. Und ein Europa League Sieg ist möglich, wird aber schwer, solange Atletico Madrid drin bleibt, wovor man ja ausgehen muss.
Was glaubst du denn, woher kommt denn, dass sich die Wahrnehmung von Arsene Wenger so geändert hat? Also eigentlich ist das ja etwas sehr Schönes, was man da sieht, dass da mal jemand nachhaltig arbeiten kann, über Jahrzehnte sogar. Und er hat ja auch den größtmöglichen Erfolg gehabt, mit der Saison der Unbesiegbaren. Ist halt nur schon eine Weile her. Liegt das daran, dass da die begeisternden Transfers gefehlt haben? Oder ist es auch die Art und Weise des Fußballs, dass man sich da zu sehr dran gewöhnt hat? Oder dass andere vielleicht jetzt auch einfach ein schönes Ballbesitz- und Fußballpassspiel aufziehen können und man deswegen nicht mehr so heraussticht?
Alle diese Faktoren spielen eine Rolle. Aber der Wichtigste ist, dass nach dem Umzug ins Emirates den Arsenal-Fans erklärt wurde, dass dieser Umzug Arsenal zu einer der größten und finanzstärksten und damit natürlich auch sportlich stärksten Mannschaften Europas werden wird. Und das ist natürlich genau nicht passiert. Das Gegenteil ist passiert. Nach 2006 hat die Mannschaft mit jedem Jahr immer mehr abgenommen, was die Leistung gerade in Europa anging. Und sechs oder sieben K.o.s im Achtelfinale sprechen natürlich eine sehr deutliche und peinliche Sprache, was die Leistung in Europa angeht. Und man hat einmal gegen Leicester vor eineinhalb Jahren tatsächlich um die Meisterschaft gespielt und hätte sie auch gewinnen müssen eigentlich. Und hat es immer wieder nicht hinbekommen. Und es ist einfach ein wahnsinniger Frust da, weil man das Gefühl hat, dass Wenger ohne jegliche Überwachung, ohne jegliche Kontrollinstanz über ihm die Mannschaft eben Stück für Stück so ins obere Mittelmaß geführt hat. Mit seinen Mitbrüdern, die einfach nicht mehr so 100 Prozent der Moderne entsprechen. Er war mal der Revolutionär, war mal der große Innovator. Aber das, was er damals völlig neu eingeführt hat, Scouting auf dem Festland, das vielleicht nicht mehr Stakes ist, um 3 Uhr vor dem Spiel, das man vielleicht nicht trinken geht am Dienstagabend bis zum Koma. Also diese Sachen sind natürlich heute völlig normal und gehören zur Orthodoxie bei den Spitzenclubs. Und dann dazu, sein Pech, gibt es eben Vereine, die deutlich mehr Geld noch ausgehen können. Also da kamen viele Dinge zusammen, aber auf jeden Fall ist bei den Fans wirklich der Appetit mittlerweile sehr groß, doch mal was Neues zu versuchen. Ich fürchte aber, dass sie sich da noch ein Jahr gedulden müssen.
Also unter anderem eine Frage der Erwartungshaltung. Und da würde sich dann bei mir die Frage stellen, wenn wir auf den FC Chelsea blicken, 8 Punkte Rückstand auf den Tabellenplatz 4. Das sieht gerade nicht so aus, als könnte man sich da noch ranspielen. Wie ist da denn die Erwartungshaltung und Lage?
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, dass für mich diese Situation nicht ganz überraschend kommt, weil das Verhältnis zwischen Konter und Vereinsführung schon im Sommer ziemlich zerrüttet war. Er war schon drauf und dran, alles hinzuschmeißen. Chelsea hörte sich damals schon unter anderem bei Thomas Tuchel um, ob man da nicht irgendwie was machen könnte, falls Konter tatsächlich im Juli von der Fahne geht. Man hat ihm dann – ich weiß gar nicht, ob das in Deutschland so angekommen ist – einen neuen Vertrag gegeben, der aber nicht verlängert wurde. Es ist sehr ungewöhnlich, jemanden mit mehr Geld zufriedenzustellen, ihm aber nicht das Vertrauen auszusprechen, noch länger da zu bleiben. Spätestens da war eigentlich klar, die Sache geht nicht gut aus. Er würde argumentieren, dass die Vereinsführung ihn, was die Transferpolitik angeht, im Stich gelassen hat, die Mannschaft nicht so ausgerichtet hat, dass sie Champions League und Premier League spielen kann mit der gleichen Bucht, mit der gleichen Qualität, die sie im Jahr davor nur in der Liga beweisen mussten, weil die Chelsea überhaupt nicht international dabei war. Und so kam es dann auch. Und jetzt müssen sie wieder von vorne anfangen und vor allem aufpassen, dass nicht so Schlüsselspieler wie Courtois oder Hazard sich irgendwann mal denken, naja, ich könnte doch eigentlich auch jedes Jahr um die Champions League spielen bei Real Madrid oder Barcelona, bin ich ja eigentlich noch richtig am Platz. Also es ist für Chelsea gerade eine schwierige Situation. Und der nächste Trainer muss auch wirklich funktionieren, was schon aus den angesprochenen Gründen gar nicht so leicht ist, weil der Markt nicht so viel hergibt.
Und du kannst uns jetzt auch wahrscheinlich nicht exklusiv rauslassen, wer da jetzt der neue Trainer wird.
Nee, ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Ich weiß, dass Leonardo Jardim wohl in der Verlosung ist. Man wird sich sicher auch mal um Max Alegi kümmern. Da gibt es verschiedene Vereine, die ihn, glaube ich, gerne verpflichten würden. Thomas Tuchel war auch im Sommer und vielleicht auch nochmal danach ein Thema, eine solche Nachfolge. Aber nach meinen Kenntnissen geht er zu PSG. Also da bleiben dann wirklich nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viele übrig. Das ist echt ein bisschen schwierig. Diego Simeone war auch mal ein großes Thema, aber da hieß es zuletzt, dass er noch bleiben wird bei Atletico. Also Chelsea tut sich da schwer, weil Chelsea natürlich auch mit diesem Art institutionalisierten Chaos immer sehr stark von den Trainern lebt. Also es ist eine ganz große Fluktuation. Aber die Trainer haben oft die Qualität, dass sie zumindest über ein oder eineinhalb Jahre dann eben auch liefern. Und dann kommt der nächste. Also es ist so ein bisschen so, dass das alte Bayern-System eigentlich sofort erster wird, wird halt ausgetauscht. Das geht auf Kosten von viel Geld und ist natürlich das Gegenteil von nachhaltiger Arbeit, ist aber gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn man sich Chelsea's Titel im Vergleich zu den sehr viel beständigeren und konzervativer handelnden Arsenal zum Beispiel anschaut.
Ja, da haben wir gerade schon drüber gesprochen. Jetzt haben wir schon wieder viel Zeit über die ersten sechs verloren, aber es gibt da noch andere 14 Mannschaften in der Premier League und auch einen Abschiegskampf, in dem unter anderem auch Hadersfield Town steckt mit einem deutschen Trainer, wie wir alle ja wissen. Was kannst du uns denn darüber so erzählen?
Ja, also Hadersfield hat auf jeden Fall schon jetzt mehr erreicht, als sie vielen zugetraut haben. Sie sind nämlich noch in der Verlosung ein paar Wochen vor Ende. Viele glaube ich, ging davon aus, dass sie das Tasmanier Berlin der Premier League werden würden, aber das ist gar nicht so. Auch Brighton als Aufsteiger hat sich hervorragend geschlagen. Es sind eher so unerwartete Teams drin, wie Crystal Palace und West Brom und West Ham. Der Abstiegskampf ist natürlich schon interessant. Ich muss jetzt aber zugestehen, dass ich allein schon aufgrund technischer Gründe fast nur die besseren Mannschaften anschaue. Denn das wissen vielleicht auch nicht immer alle Zuhörer. In England sieht man sehr wenig von der Premier League. Es kommen nämlich nur – anders als in Deutschland – nur drei bis vier Spieler live am Wochenende. Was den angenehmen Nebeneffekt hat, dass man die nicht so guten Mannschaften dann auch nicht so oft sieht. Vielleicht eines der Geheimnisse auch der großen Strahlkraft ist der Premier League, weil diese Spiele dann – ja, zumindest live technisch – unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit stattfinden.
Das heißt, als Fan von Southampton oder Stoke City kann ich meine Mannschaft gar nicht an jedem Spieltag sehen, wenn ich nicht vor Ort im Stadion bin?
Korrekt. Also gerade Southampton West Ham siehst du vielleicht deine Mannschaft 10-12 Mal im Jahr live.
Verrückt. Das wusste ich auch nicht. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich ist dann Radio das Informationsmedium und wahrscheinlich Live-Ticker. Und so hält man sich dann über seine Mannschaft auf dem Laufenden.
Ja, oder du suchst dir halt irgendwelche illegalen Streams.
Stimmt.
Seitdem waren so griechische Satelliten-Abus sehr beliebt, denn die haben ähnlich wie der Zone oder ähnlich auch wie NBC in Amerika nämlich alles gezeigt. Aber innerhalb Europas hat die Premier League das jetzt auch so gemacht, das hat man ja schon vor ein paar Jahren bei Sky in Deutschland auch erlebt, dass immer weniger Spiele eigentlich gezeigt wurden. Also, dass dann teilweise nur noch ein bis zwei Spiele live kamen. Auch aus dem Grund, um dann eben die Premier League vor Ort weiter zu schützen mit ihrem doch relativ spartanischen Angebot. Aber deswegen muss ich sagen, dass ich diese Mittelklasse-Mannschaften gar nicht so oft zu Gesicht bekomme. Ich finde Newcastle immer ganz schön, gerade wenn die zu Hause spielen, weil es halt so eine traditionelle Wucht noch entfacht und immer so ein bisschen Stimmung. Diese Mischung aus Größenwahn und Humor und Selbstironie mitschwingt bei den Geordies. Ansonsten hast du natürlich einfach mit sechs Mannschaften weitaus mehr gute Mannschaften als irgendwo sonst. Das ist tatsächlich in diesem Jahr, nicht nur in diesem Jahr, aber in diesem Jahr vielleicht besonders, einfach ausgeprägt, dass es eben dann jede Woche auch eine Art von Spitzen-Spiel gibt, dass es sich wirklich lohnt zu schauen, wenn ich dann überlege, jetzt am Montag gibt es Leipzig gegen Leverkusen, Vierter gegen Fünfter, das wird bestimmt gar nicht schlecht das Spiel, aber es hat natürlich nicht diesen Glanz und nicht dieses, ja, diesen Glamour, dieses absolute Muss-Ich-muss-das-anschauen-Gefühl, das die dementsprechende Partie jetzt in der Premier League hätte, wenn es mal zu überlegen, Vierter, das ist…
Die Spurs gegen Chelsea wäre das. Aber wie macht man denn das dann eigentlich vor Ort, dass man sich über andere Mannschaften kundig macht? Ist man dann auf Spielberichte, Zusammenfassungen angewiesen? Du erlebst mich gerade wirklich leicht schockiert. Ich verdiene ja inzwischen ein Teil meines Gelbedes damit, alles an Bundesliga live zu sehen, was ich in ein Wochenende packen kann. Und da würde ich mir zwar manchmal wünschen, dass so manches nicht übertragen worden wäre und ich deswegen das gar nicht hätte sehen können. Aber es hat mir schon jetzt im Laufe der Zeiten, finde ich, ein Wissen gegeben über viele Mannschaften, über die ich vorher eher ein Halbwissen hatte. Also ich kann jetzt auch sehr fundierte Sachen, hoffe ich zumindest, über Augsburg, Hannover usw. sagen, die vorher nicht in meinem Fokus waren.
Ja, also das ist wirklich was nur für absolute Hardcore-Fans, die sich dann ab 8 oder ab 9 auf Sky komplette Spiele nochmal anschauen können, die sozusagen im Real-Life ausgestrahlt werden. Oder zumindest in längeren Zusammenfassungen. Oder dann das Äquivalent der Sportshow, bzw. des Sportstudios um halb 11 meistens bei Match of the Day. Längere Zusammenfassung. Aber selbst da hat man als Huddersfield oder Crystal Palace Fan oft schlechte Karten, denn da wird streng nach Attraktivität des Spiels. Was gar nicht unbedingt jetzt auch an den Namen aufgezogen wird. Denn wenn Man United gegen Southampton 0-0 spielt, dann kann es auch mal sein, dass sie dann tatsächlich ganz am Ende laufen und nur fünf Minuten gezeigt werden. Weil es irgendwo anders einen 3-3 gegeben hat. Also das schützt sozusagen nicht davor, da ein bisschen vernachlässigt zu werden. Aber es ist nicht so leicht. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass das vielleicht auch ein bisschen Kalkül ist und Teil des Appeals zu sagen, wir machen das Produkt eigentlich rar. Und wir zeigen eben nicht diese ganze Ausschussware, sondern eigentlich nur die Premium-Spiele.
Ja, ich glaube, aus Konsumenten sich kann ich das sehr gut nachvollziehen, aber das ist ja dann wahnsinnig schwierig. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel gerade eine Saison, wo alle drei Aussteiger aktuell stand, 31. Spieltag, 32. Spieltag, je nachdem, welchen man da heranziehen will, nicht auf einem Abschiebsplatz stehen. Und dann ist es für die doch wahnsinnig schwierig, daraus einen positiven Bass zu erzeugen, der sich bei ihnen dann auch monetär widerschlägt. Also man will ja Tickets verkaufen, Merchandise-Artikel usw. Das ist ja schon neben dem ganzen TV-Geld auch noch eine Einnahmequelle in der Premier League. Und das ist ja dann kaum zu schaffen, wenn man dann trotzdem nur gezeigt wird, wenn man mal entweder ein Highlight-Spiel hatte, wo man 4-4 gespielt hat, oder halt gegen einen der großen 6 antritt, gegen die man ja aber meistens verliert.
Ja, das ist einer der Faktoren, warum die Merchandising- und Sponsorenrechte einfach nicht so relevant sind im Vergleich zu dem, was in der Bundesliga umgesetzt wird. Aber die Bundesliga zahlt natürlich da den Preis wiederum dafür, dass die Fernsehrechte gut in den letzten Jahren sehr viel Zuwachs verzeichnet werden können. Aber jahrelang war natürlich der Wert der Fernsehrechte dadurch gedeckelt, dass ganz viel free-to-air Bundesliga lief, fast schon zu Kick-off-Zeiten. Also kurz nach Ende der Spiele. Das kam dann über die Sponsorengelder wieder rein. In der Premier League ist das Thema einfach mal – Fernsehrechte ist Nummer 1. Und da das relativ gleichmäßig verteilt wird, ist es dann auch nicht so wichtig, ob ich jetzt dann laufe oder nicht. Also das wird nach einem Schlüssel aufgeteilt, der relativ gleichmäßig ist. Das heißt, der erste kriegt nicht wahnsinnig viel mehr als der letzte, obwohl er natürlich öfters läuft und dann natürlich über Sponsoring, Merchandising und so weiter vielleicht auch mehr generieren kann. Aber diese Nebeneinkünfte, sage ich mal, fallen gar nicht so ins Gewicht, weil einfach die Fernsehrechte alles überstrahlen und das einfach das Wichtigste ist. Deswegen ist es den Vereinen so, wie es jetzt gerade ist, ganz recht. Und das Wahnsinnige ist, dass die Premier League ja noch wahnsinnige Ressourcen hat. Also wenn man jetzt morgen sagen würde, alle Spiele sind nicht mehr zwischen 3 und 5, denn da darf seit den 60er Jahren nach dem Erlass eines Gesetzes überhaupt kein Live-Fußball laufen in Großbritannien. Also sagen wir mal, wir verlegen alle Spiele auf Samstagabend oder Sonntag Nachmittag, zeigen dafür alle Spiele live, 10 mal 38. Dann könnte man theoretisch nochmal vielleicht das doppelte Umsetzen von dem, was jetzt umgesetzt wird, mit gut die Hälfte von allen Spielen. Also das ist eigentlich erschreckend, wenn man das vergleicht mit der Bundesliga, wo schon seit 2000 Jahren alle Spiele einfach verramscht sind, vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber einfach mal verschleudert werden. Weil man da das Gefühl hatte damals, dass so ein bisschen gegen die Marktgesetze spricht, mehr Angebot verschärft dann vielleicht auch die Nachfrage. Aber das hat sich nicht so als die richtige Strategie erwiesen.
Und dann geht es jetzt auf Montags-Spiele, wo heute beschlossen wurde, die DFL hält daran fest, also dann die Vereine halten daran fest, die Montags-Spiele sollen bleiben. Da müssen sich die Bundesliga-Fans dran gewöhnen. Letzte Frage, weil ich weiß, dass du auch vielen anderen europäischen Fußball im Blick hast. Wird in der Premier League deiner Meinung nach der beste Fußball gespielt?
Die Frage mit dem besten Fußball ist immer schwer, wie man das wirklich definiert. Wenn man alleine die Erfolge heranzieht in den letzten Jahren, muss man natürlich sagen, dass in Spanien der beste Fußball gespielt wird. Zumindest der erfolgreichste.
Aber was guckst du dir am liebsten an? Wenn du jetzt die Wahl hast, Spitzenspiel, Bundesliga, 1. Division oder La Liga, Serie A, Ligue 1 oder Premier League?
Ich glaube grundsätzlich, dass Leute eigentlich gar keine Ligen schauen, sondern Mannschaften. Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand sagt von sich, ich bin Fan der Premier League. Klar, als interessierter Zuschauer schaut man das gerne. Aber wirklich intensiv, so wie man als echter Fan seine Mannschaft verfolgt, da geht es darum, wer diese Mannschaften sind. Wenn ich jetzt vor der Wahl stehe, Huddersfield gegen Brighton anzuschauen, weil sie in der Premier League spielen, oder Barcelona gegen Madrid, oder selbst Lassist Milan gegen Inter sein, dann ist irgendwie klar, wie diese Wahl ausfällt. Es geht weniger darum, wo diese Mannschaften spielen, als was für eine Art Fußball und Qualität sie stehen. Da schaue ich mir genauso gerne die Dortmunder Mannschaft von Thomas Tuchel oder die Bayernmannschaft von Pep und mit Abstrichen von Jupp an, wie die Spurs und wie Barcelona. Das ist für mich eher eine Frage der Mannschaften und der Qualität als der Ligen. Ich glaube, dass viele Konsumenten – schlimmes Wort jetzt in dem Zusammenhang, aber wenn man es global betrachtet – ähnlich denken. Das ist natürlich das eigentliche Problem der Bundesliga. Das Problem der Bundesliga ist nicht, dass die Liga nicht ausgeglichen ist. Das ist natürlich nicht wünschenswert. Aber ich weiß es eben aus Erfahrung, als die Liga unglaublich ausgeglichen war und man nicht wusste, ob Mannschaften wie Stuttgart oder Wolfsburg oder sogar Dortmund mal Meister werden, hat das keinen Menschen interessiert. Das Interesse kam erst, als Bayern und Dortmund auf einmal zu europäischen Spitzen-Teams wurden und man das Gefühl hatte, das steht für echte Qualität und die können jeden auf der Welt besiegen. Dann auf einmal gab es Interesse daran. Und da muss die Bundesliga einfach wieder wieder aufholen und es kann nicht sein, dass es neben den Bayern einfach überhaupt niemanden gibt.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Mir ist gerade aufgefallen, dass ich gelogen habe. Es war die vorletzte Frage. Die letzte Frage ist nämlich, dein aktuelles Buch Bring the Noise über Jürgen Klopp. Würdest du empfehlen, dass das des englischen mächtigen Leser auf Englisch lesen oder in der deutschen Übersetzung?
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Also das Buch wurde auf Englisch – ich habe es auf Englisch geschrieben. Und der eine oder andere Wortwitz oder diese typisch englischen Fußballformulierungen lassen sich am Anfang ins Deutsche nicht so übertragen. Also würde ich sagen, einerseits das englische Original lesen, andererseits sind natürlich ganz viele wichtige Charaktere im deutschen Original auch noch so ein bisschen in ihrer eigenen Mundart eigentlich amüsanter und interessanter zu lesen. Also das parale Beispiel dafür ist natürlich Christian Heidel, der so eine unnachahmliche Art und Weise hat, die Dinge auszudrücken und das im Original natürlich irgendwann besser rüberkommen, finde ich.
Also hast du uns jetzt quasi gerade gesagt, wir sollen beides kaufen?
Ja, gerne auch noch die dänische Fassung dazu. Dann hat man alle und nächstes Jahr auch in Polen.
Okay, werden wir natürlich tun. Ich kann nur sagen, ich habe das Reboot, dein Buch über die deutsche Nationalmannschaft damals im englischen Original gelesen und fand es für einen, der auch englische Serien guckte, sehr, sehr, sehr gut verständlich. Also brauchen da die Hörerinnen und Hörer keine Angst vor der Sprachbarriere haben. Das war Raphael Honigstein.
Ich habe noch einen kurzen Plug, wie man so schön sagt. Das nächste Buch ist auch schon fertig. Und zwar ist das die Autobiografie von Per Mertesacker.
Ach ja, klar, super.
Die mit dem schönen Titel erscheint – Weltmeister ohne Talent.
Das hätte auch… Ah nee, ich will zu niemandem zu nahe treten. Nein, da möchte ich jetzt keinen Witz darüber machen. Wir lassen es einfach so stehen. Sehr gut zu wissen, es kommt noch an der Per Mertesacker Biografie. Ich habe den Eindruck, Raphael, wir müssen auch mal miteinander im Rasenfunk sprechen. Da kannst du dann auch nochmal über Per Mertesacker mir ein paar Geschichten erzählen. Vielen, vielen Dank dir. Das war Raphael Honigstein, Ed Honigstein auf Twitter. Und das war Kurzpass Nummer 51, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Man kann den Rasenfunk unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen und dabei helfen, dass es mehr solcher Folgen gibt. Und wenn ihr irgendwann genügend spendet, dann kann ich auch so tollen Autoren wie dem Raphael ein Honorar zahlen. Das ist das Ziel für die Zukunft. Schaffen wir nur mit euch zusammen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. In diesem Sinne, eine gute Zeit euch und bis zum nächsten Mal im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao!